you talk in the book that you say that
your favorite and you've had so many
great jobs I mean you uh in your life
you achieved all these great dreams you
said your favorite job ever was being
governor of California yeah alltime
favorite job it was the toughest job the
toughest job without any doubt because
to bring 120 legislators together and
make them agree on anything it's kind of
like impossible but we made it possible
we figured it out and um
I think that to
serve 40 million people and to be the
governor of the greatest state in the
Union greatest state in the country out
of 50 States California is we by far the
greatest state with the most revenues
and the most power the most diversity in
all unbelievable and not only that but
we are actually now the fourth largest
economy in the world so to be governed
of that it's just unbelievable the
responsibility and uh you learn a lot I
mean it was the most extraordinary
learning experience to sit in that
capital and to have meetings think about
that uh if have a meeting from 9 to 10:
with the nurses Union and they want to
have a better ratio between the patients
and nurses if you know for for every uh
four patients one nurse rather than for
every six patients one nurse mhm
and I never even heard of that before
the racial so you learn about all of
that and what is it that nurses go
through and why is it important because
when they lift a patient from the
operating table you know under their bed
the two women cannot sometimes do it if
it's a heavier patient so they need a
male patient there so they were fighting
also they have male patients that they
little stronger to do lift the all of
this so all of this stuff I've never
even heard of those debates then then
the prison guards come in and say we
working so many over so much overtime
that we need to have more prison guards
we need to hire more and we have to have
more salaries and more wages and more
benefits and all so they talk about that
issue then the the teachers come in the
teachers union they talk about the you
know teaching and the challenges
teachers go through then the people they
represent the kids comeing so this is
how it goes on and on and on from
morning to night and it's always issues
that you have not really been aware of
so in the beginning it was kind of like
a university where you study new
subjects and new issues all the time and
you become so smart with all of this
stuff and I had one advantage and that
was I was not a real ideologue you know
yes I was conservative yes I'm a
republican but I'm not stuck in this
ideological corner and I didn't look at
the Democrats as the enemy I always felt
kind of like in order to make this work
you have to have Democrats and
Republicans work together so we work
together and we figured out what is it
that we can do together and then let's
fight over the other issues people are
so hungry for that and so that is really
what we did and that's why we were able
to do build all this infrastructure and
why we were able to do the the
redistricting reform and get rid of
cherry mentoring and why we were able to
go and pick so many minority judges and
women and and all this so we were able
to do things and the environmental
issues that we tackled I mean this the
only state that really reduced its
greenhouse gases its pollution by 25%
within 10 years so there was a lot of
great stuff that was going on but
together Democrats and Republicans
together did this work not me not the
Republicans but Democrats and
Republicans here's what really I took
away from your book and and what you're
saying right now is early in your career
it's you and you H are in a situation
where you can control your body you can
control what you do to your body and how
you build build your body you can be in
full control as a bodybuilder then
control was very important to you when
you got into movies how can I prepare
myself what roles are right for me what
roles are wrong for me if I'm going to
do a comedy what should that comedy be
and what would the best way for me to
how could I best you show my humor what
would work who's the best this who's the
best that when you become governor you
put yourself in a situation where a
governor can do so much it's almost like
you willfully put yourself in a
situation where you don't have a lot of
control there's a lot you can't control
when a job is that big do you think
there was some part of you that was
pushing you into a situation where you
can't control everything all you can do
is try but you there's a lot you can't
control yeah you're absolutely right but
you don't want to yeah you know because
you don't want the dictatorship you
don't want to have one person make all
of the decisions because we're not
perfect right you know and sometimes
that goes overboard and you start going
power crazy and stuff like that so you
need always to have a check in balance I
think that's really terrific but what
you can do in where you have total
control over is motivating people to
move forward and to do great things so
it doesn't matter what your philosophy
is but to say we must sit down guys and
we guys got to build more highways and
freeways more tunnels and bridges more
on ramps and off ramps more school
buildings my University buildings
affordable housing let's do it we can do
it you know so now they go and they go
you know oh this is great and they sit
down and you can motivate so you become
kind of the motivator and the force
behind bringing people together and
creating a vision like I said in the
book you know visualizing is the most
important thing I had very clear visions
of course crazy visions of what
California can be I visualized I told
them I visualize you know every city
having a thousand
cranes and we're building and building
and building new dams new highways new
this new that no and it was crazy Vision
but you have to have a vision but it
motivated them to sit down and that we
were able to do $60 billion of
infrastructure half of what I wanted but
we did it and so this is really the
great thing so I think that one thing we
have control over motivating and that's
one of the things I feel like is missing
today there is no one in
Washington that is really ring up the
troops and is motivating them and
becoming kind of like their the the
motivational kind of behind it to bring
people together because there's a way of
doing it there's a way of doing it
there's people people are not saying I
don't want to get together with the
other side I think you just need someone
that motivates them and really make it
attractive and kind of like talk to them
and communicate the right way and so
this is I there's certain powers that we
do have that was that I was able to use
and I was always a positive person you
know me I mean it was never kind of like
I always see the world kind of like uh
Norman Rockwell you know Norman Rockwell
he always painted everything that was
fun kind of optimistic ex optimistic and
fun and colorful and stuff so that's the
way I that's the lens that I look
through when I look at America or when I
look at any of the issues or the
problems anything it's always through
that lens I see it bright I since don't
see it dark and black and white or
anything like this I always see it
bright and there's a bright future ahead
and I think that that to me is much more
helpful than always being depressed and
say oh my God things are terrible things
are going downhill and all that yeah I
was I was very impressed too which I
didn't realize in the book is you had uh
uh surgery that was supposed to be
routine just a couple of years ago and
something went very wrong in the surgery
and it was touch and go oh yeah I mean I
was really pissed off and you I can tell
you that think about it Go pissed off
that I had a life and death experience
but I mean think about it I mean you go
in there and you say they say it's a
twoh hour procedure yeah and the next
thing you know is you wake up and they
say okay this is 16 hours later yeah and
you're trying to talk and you
go said well no don't don't try to talk
arold you still have this thing put a tu
tube in your throat and so they they not
put the tube out of my
throat you know I'm coughing and they
say all right let us explain to you
things went South we punctured through
the hard wall with the wire accidentally
this was the wire that's supposed to go
up and remove your old valve a oric
valve and then the other wire was
supposed to replace that and put a new
atic valve in but back backs and we
punched punctured through the wall and
it created internal bleeding that we had
to do an emergency opening of your rib
cage rip everything open very quickly
otherwise you would have died
and now we had to then do this and this
that then then we by accident also
damaged the uh other valve and this is
how it went on and so now 16 hours later
but we we saved you he said well that is
really
fantastic I had to kind of like what I
call their shifting gears you know I had
to shift gears because now this thing
like going after in the afternoon then
out and and uh you know uh having a good
time was out the window now I'm trying
to survive and this is to just to
reiterate you thought you were going in
for arthoscopic or
orthoscopic thing and then you go home
that night and have your pizza and pet
your donkey and then you wake up 16
hours later and they took all of your
insides out and put them back in upside
down ex that's right exactly so I mean
so this is what what what happened and
so now you have to shift gears because
now you have to say when they tell you
that uh you're not out of the woods yet
because what happens a lot of times they
say is you can die because of pneumonia
MH and so this is why it's very
important that within a day you must get
out of bed and you got to go and start
walking to really get lung exercises
because that's what usually drips you up
and so it's very very important that I I
now start setting my mind okay I'm going
to go and I'm going to get out of bed as
soon as they will me from this station
over to my bedroom I'm going to get out
of the bed you know no matter what and
I'm going to start walking and so this
becomes like the mission you know to
start walking I don't want to die
because of pneumonia I've gotten through
the surgery and blah blah blah and so
you know it was kind of a touch andg go
situation the first few days but then I
got stronger and stronger and three
months later I started with the
Terminator 6 yeah I started filming 3
months later I started filming again
they couldn't believe it on said and I
was back again working out regularly and
all this stuff so you know I think that
again with the positive way of thinking
and I can do it and nothing is going to
stop me you know with that kind of an
attitude I was able to do that this book
is I recommend it to everyone be useful
seven tools for life I recommend it
because the
the quality that comes through again and
again and again in this book that's
really sweet is humility you have a lot
of humility for someone who is almost
like the cartoon representation of you
can do it all and achieve everything
you're very very humble and uh you have
a lot of empathy for people who maybe
don't have some of your qualities or
struggle you have an incredible amount
of empathy and I could see that when you
made these videos after January 6th and
Ukraine and that really spoke to me and
I thought God I I'm happy this this
man's out there and he's doing this now
with his platform so much thank you I I
love being a motivational speaker out
there and writing a motivational book
and having a motivational newsletter
that is out there every day and uh to do
all those kind of things the pump club
and all this you know I I felt kind of
like I was motivated my whole life by
people and I want to motivate other
people now millions of people around the
world that's my mission I feel motivated
so I don't I mean I don't think you're
motivated oh oh you don't um she's not
very motivated but I think I'm motivated
stuck in your hate Ashbury
days she well I I I see that you're
motivated I don't know why Conan is
after you I mean it's like you're the
only woman in this room and who is he
attacking oh my God unbelievable May
You're motivated to quit you know what
I'm saying I'm going to start a rumor
that he has a hostile work
environment it's not a rumor it's not a
rumor I will back all I need right now
not it's not a rumor it's not a rumor
it's not a rumor it's not a rumor yes
Arnold Schwarzenegger thank you very
much God
bless